hi so my name is jamella smith del and i
am working in the stranno lab which is a
chemical engineering NanoLab and i'm
working on continuous 1d thermal power
wave generator so basically the problem
that we're dealing with in our love is
portable power sources are not reliable
in the sense that you have to constantly
recharge them in order for them to
actually operate so for example your
cell phone imagine having to not
recharge your cell phone every single
night so basically what we're looking at
is increasing the efficiency of our
portable power sources also looking into
fuel cells that are able to convert
chemical energy to electrical energy so
the two main objectives are to design a
fuel cell which has a higher efficiency
as well as increasing the operability of
these fuel cells in the market so here's
a Seebeck effect I won't go too far into
the actual theory but basically you see
here this is the delta T or the thermal
energy which is converted to the voltage
or the electrical energy and this is a
flux so basically the related work in
the shadow lab is in the in the past
semesters I've worked with him and
designing a single of a thermal power
wave generator so in this image this is
these are carbon nanotubes that are held
together by a structure we coat these
carbon nanotubes similar to this photo
we coat it with fuel light it with a
jewel heater and this jewel heater
provides enough thermal energy for the
actual reaction to occur so it's a
combustion reaction and the flame front
travels from one end to the other
because of the chemical potential of the
actual device